[Music]
we've been using substances for millions
of years as survival tools what's
different is that today we've sort of
scaled up the psychoactive component and
made it just abundant anywhere right so
it's very easy to get and the part that
makes you feel something is very
[Music]
strong woo what's up this is John with
the Dr John show show about your mental
health your marriage your emotional
health getting outside and changing your
life it's a show about changing your
family
tree I'm John and I've been doing this
for two decades sitting with hurting
people when the wheels have fallen off
and my promise is I may not know the
exact answer but I will sit with you and
we will figure out what to do next if
you want to be on the show go to
john.com
askas fill out the form and we will
we'll see if we can get you on we get we
get calls and notes from all over the
planet and so um we love to have you as
a part of the show and today's a really
incredible day
um so a number of you wrote in and said
hey we love having the occasional
interview please um if you have somebody
who's great that you think we should
know please bring it on um bring them on
and listen um gosh it's probably a year
ago now I got a hold of um Dr AA petera
strongly recommended reading a book and
so whenever he's one of the few people
and he says read this book I read that
book and I read the book it's called The
Comfort crisis by Michael Easter I
finished the book I immediately walked
into my 12-year-old son's room and I
handed him the book I did black out a
few words just because I don't know I'm
I'm an oldfashioned guy but I handed it
to my 12-year-old and I said everything
stops in your life until you read this
book and then we're going to go to
breakfast and talk about it and he
rolled his eyes and he started reading
it and he didn't put it down and so you
have a guy here with two phds who read
this book and was profoundly changed and
moved and I handed it to my 12-year-old
and it captured him like a Harry Potter
novel and it has opened up some
incredible conversations that a year
later it it's become part of the fabric
of our life the author of The Comfort
crisis like I said is by Michael Easter
um who's an incredible guy and an
incredible writer spent time writing for
a men's health for many years has spent
years in the publishing industry wrote
The Comfort crisis and has a brand new
book out called scarcity
brain this is a book that I was so
excited to get um so in the publishing
World they actually they'll send us
media copies they send us free copies of
the book to read and to see if we'll
have somebody on our show when I saw
that it was in pre-sale I actually
bought it with my own money I went and
got it I wanted to get it as soon as I
possibly could and um my my Michael's
been a friend now for for a while and
man having him on the show is just
incredible we talk about addiction talk
about how addiction works and not just
addiction to drugs but addiction to work
addiction to what other people think
about us addiction to certain kinds of
food addiction we also talk about what
to do with all of this
Comfort something that sounds so strange
something that we all want and desire
yet it's killing us we talk about the
question of God we talk about so much
it's one of my favorite conversations
I've ever had so buckle up turn up the
volume a little bit on your headphones
if you're listening to us that
way check out my conversation with the
great and extraordinary Mr Michael
Easter hey thanks for being with us it's
awesome um so you've
written um you and I've told you this
personally I think I reached out to you
which I almost never do um I this is in
the top five most important books I've
read in the last decade and um I told
you I finished the Comfort crisis and I
immediately walked into my son who was
12 at the time I was like you have to
read this book and then um I did
something I almost never do I bought
aa's book and I bought like out of my
own money I bought your book and what
most like Insider baseball when
somebody's getting going to press tour
they often will send out a bunch of
copies and I don't want to wait I was
like no no I have to have this book at
my house and it's another just
Masterpiece dude it's so good and I
trust you enough I sent you an early
copy of mine and you said I think these
things overlap a lot and this morning I
just sat there as I was going over notes
for this and I thought oh my gosh you
just wrote a better version of of the
book I was trying to put together that's
not true it is but you you um so I'm
excited to dig into this I want to start
with
um a new picture of addiction I've
struggled with it you've been really
open about your adventures with
addiction and I want to frame up
addiction 101 was moral failure forever
if you have an addiction if you can't
stop drinking if you can't stop looking
at pornography if you can't stop
something it's cuz you're weak and you
suck and you're a bad person right and
then there was this shift and I've heard
it a couple different ways but the the
one that makes the most sense
is the only path towards compassion in
our country both with theological with
with faith communities and with the
medical community is to label something
a disease if I stamp it with disease
then the church is like oh you're not a
bad person then you can come to a
Recovery Group at our building or if
it's not a moral failure if it's a
disease then health insurance will cover
it right and so we've lived under this
disease model and quietly over the last
probably 20 years working with college
students which is a huge that's that's
where this the epicenter of some of this
starts it's been this very
disempowering students come in slumped
over right not like I have a huge test
and I'm going to go get it or you talk
to students right before the bar exam
and they're scared to death but they're
also like I'm GNA get this thing
students coming in saying I got a
disease I've got a thing and it's just
just going to be my life and it's it's a
it's a giving up and then there's been a
different conversation maybe the last 10
or 15 years and it's funny because I
used to always tell college students
parents um hey your kid's drinking
because it works it works it works great
until it doesn't right until it kills
you like cocaine's incredible it works
until until it kills you right and I had
never seen it laid out and then there's
some authors that have said you know
addiction is just connection and that's
not that doesn't go far enough so paint
us a new picture because I I feel like
both the psychiatrists that I'm talked
to Behind Closed Doors the psychologist
and and medical researchers that I'm
talking to and then folks like you and I
who have experienced this and who meet
with other people regularly and you
travel the world for this book um paint
us a new picture of what addiction might
actually be so yeah you have to start
with um I think you have to go back in
history and you have to look at um how
have humans traditionally used
substances and in scarcity brain I argue
we've been using substances for millions
of years as survival tools so if you
think about alcohol alcohol's role um as
humans were evolv is that it would give
off a scent from rotting fruit you
needed food you couldn't find it right
so you smell this you're like oh that's
food that's going to keep me alive so
you go eat the food right um we apples
fall from a tree and they just sit on
the ground exactly they start they to
ferment you smell that it's like bam we
just found a lot of food great uh things
like cocaine so for example cocaine is
made from coces now COC are still used
as basically like coffee in um a lot of
countries in South America because it
increases your focus a little bit right
now the actual cocaine component is very
very minimal so we've always used these
things to survive so with the example of
the cocoa Leaf hones your focus on a
long hunt it keeps you going when you're
in these long searches for food in the
past when food was scarce Etc and you
can basically apply that logic to most
substances um but I think what's
different is that today we've sort of
scaled up the psychoactive component and
made it just abundant anywhere right
right so it's very easy to get it's
cheap and the part that um yeah makes
you feel something is very strong so we
still use these as tools though right
I'll you you mentioned uh me I'll take
me as an example I don't drink anymore
but the reason I started drinking is
because it enhanced my life made your
life better for aason made my life
better full stop and we don't talk about
that enough exactly and how did it make
it better A lot of I mean so I've had to
unpack why I drink in the first first
place um if I was at a social event it
was a social lubricant um but also I've
always been a person who is drawn to
sort of extreme experiences right like
still today I go on these long
Backcountry hunts or I'll go to these
countries that where there's a lot a lot
happening you know um and alcohol can
alcohol gave me that this sort of it
sort of lessen the rains it was like
anything could happen if you have a
bunch of drinks you don't know what's
going to happen like you're going to be
up for anything and that improved my
life now at a certain point that stops
working right you keep trying to chase
that um good thing that you get from it
over and over and over and eventually it
starts paying back now the the the
problem is that you've learned this
behavior that you are absolutely
convinced and have all this past
evidence improves your
life and if you are an addict using your
substance of choice or behavior of
choice it still enhances your life in
the short term it does so even when I
was at my worst with drinking if I took
a drink my life would get better at
least in the short term the problem is
is that it begins to create long-term
problems the evidence mounts on the
other side like this isn't helping right
right right and it's hard to it's hard
to split that apart yeah you can't see
that in the moment because you've
learned this thing that always worked
and then it stops working and you're
like why isn't this working anymore
maybe I just need to try it again and
let's do more yeah let's do more maybe I
just didn't do enough right uh and so
that's a hard cycle to get out of I
think it's more I really think of
addiction as more a
um in a way in the addict's mind it's
kind of a solution to problems um but I
think really what underlies it is it's a
symptom of something else you're trying
to take care of so for me it was just
that like I kind of had a boring life at
the height of my drinking right like I
didn't have a filling job I wasn't able
to get out and do these other things
that would have given me this like
stimulation that I needed to thrive as a
human being and I could find that um
through alcohol even though it was you
know leading to problems in the long
term but it could be it could be any
behavior for other different people you
know you you and I had dinner last night
and we were talking about our
jobs I think that's an important thing
to put a to put a pin in your job at the
time was like a great job and probably
one you were pretty excited to get right
I mean you were a writer for a
prestigious publication I am 100%
confident I read your articles back at
my house because I subscribed to several
of the magazines you were a part of
creating and so how much of that boring
job is is a gap between if I get this
job then I'm going to be good and I get
this job and then all a sudden it's like
oh i' do this for the rest of my life we
used to joke with actors with my acting
students like hey if you go to Broadway
and you get cats congratulations you're
a cat for the next 30 years of your life
twice a day you'll never have a weekend
again like you you got there and it's
like oh gosh you know what I mean but
how much of that boredom there's reality
it's just punch and punch and punch but
there had to be annoying sense of Oh I
thought when I got
here that then I'd be okay with Michael
well I think that that's a story of a
lot of different things in life right so
when I was reporting the Comfort crisis
for example I traveled to Bhutan and uh
I go meet with this guy who's a Kempo in
the Buddhist face so this is like pretty
high up and um he had lived in America
for a while he was the was a boyfriend
of the translator for the dolly Lama so
he'd lived in Atlanta he'd kind of seen
how Americans live and now he's back in
Bhutan and he lives in this Shack that's
like on a cliff there's not electricity
it's like a bucket system for water and
he looks at me and he goes you know a
lot of times uh people in the west they
live life like it's a
checklist and once you check the box oh
that's what's going to make me happy but
then you check the box and you
go what what's that other box there
what's the next one I can check and then
it's that search right and so it kind of
is this constant uh dissatisfaction can
happen but I think that in my case um
yeah you know I thought that this like
oh I got this job that everyone's heard
of this place that I work at I'm doing
all this writing but the reality was is
that it wasn't as exciting as you might
think it never is yeah you know I had um
I couldn't write things that I actually
wanted to write about a lot of times I
had editors who would chop it up um I
couldn't get out in the world and meet
like I got into journalism to go to go
places to be on the ground to meet
people to learn information and I
couldn't do a lot of that and um yeah it
just wasn't as exciting as you might
think on paper and so in order to find
that excitement well Friday and Saturday
okay let's go out to the bars let's
drink a bunch let's see what's going to
happen right it it very much was a r the
dice totally it's like you don't know
what's going to happen you might close
down this bar you know singing Friends
in Low Places with some people you've
never met and like wow that's crazy or
it might be like you know oh we're going
to go into this totally new area of town
and like we're going to this place and
there's just all these different things
or it could even be writing right I
could sit down and crank out these words
that I otherwise might not have had I
been sober and so it's it was very much
um an exploration of the edges in way
that uh ultimately led to long-term
problems so you know addiction would we
wouldn't even call it addiction
substance use wouldn't be a problem if
like yeah I had a bunch of drinks and
then I went and volunteered and then I
donated some money to charity and then I
all these good things right the problem
is is that it leads to behaviors that
aren't good for society often
so I think the scary thing about framing
addiction as first a behavior that works
so if I'm talking to a mom and a a dad
and has a 12-year-old that's already
showing signs of
addiction it's easy to want to blame a
12-year-old want to blame the substance
and not ask the harder question which is
what is happening in that kid's world
that their body is finding Avenues to
escape from like whether that's getting
bullied at school whether that's y all
keep fighting whether that's dad you're
not at home and that kid feels that
attenion and if I look at I'll just use
the United States if we look at the
escalating addiction rates across the
board on Netflix hours worked
pornography drugs whatever want to say I
think the
easy solution is it's a disease the easy
solution is well you're bad and you're
bad and you're bad the harder question
is what kind of culture have we created
that everybody has everything and
they're so desperate to escape from it
that to me is a scarier question
culturally right it takes harder work
it's not as black and white yeah right
so humans
we don't like uncertainty we don't like
complexity it's much easier if you can
just say yep bad person wrong decision
oh absolutely 100% a sick person it's a
disease um I think kind of what we're
getting at here is usually there's some
underlying reason a person would use a
substance or do a behavior in the first
place and it's probably going to be
different for everyone but uncovering
that is um is difficult work it's it's
not really fun no
uh so I think that part of getting sober
is having to ask those hard questions
why am I using this in the first place
so I think addiction basically needs
three things to happen you need to have
a person who is in pain or has problems
you need um a lack of being able to
solve those problems in a better way or
deal with that pain in a more productive
way not a lot of outlets and then you
need a substance that quickly solves
that problem that it's abundant more or
less and you see that that's like the
story of most drug epidemics right so in
the book I travel to Iraq there wasn't
much addiction there for a long time a
lot of that was because uh Saddam ruled
with a iron fist then what happens is
you have the US military Invasion so it
destabilizes the country you have a lot
of people who have lived through the
trauma of a war for a long time and then
um in 2017 the country Syria Falls and
they basically become a Narco state so
their main export right now is this drug
called captagon which is this new sort
of uh it's analogous to methamp meth
yeah yeah that's meth um and it starts
floating over the borders so you have
this population of people who have all
these traumas from war there's not a lot
of great outlets for that in Iraq it's
not like there's you know Psychiatry
offices on every corner that would help
them find another way out of that and
then you have this substance flood in
that immediately gets you out of your
problems at least in the short term it
allows you to sort of escape from that
and so because of that you see addiction
really Spike same thing with um you know
why did the opioid epidemic really boom
in a lot of the places that used to be
steel manufactures it's like well all
the jobs leave took away people's
purpose yeah you're jobless you're
hopeless and then all of a sudden we get
this flood of opioids and that can solve
a lot of problems that were brought on
by not having a sort of Bright Horizon
to look out on to right it's like a very
dark Horizon to be like well I've lost
my job there's no more jobs coming in I
don't have any other skill than this one
that I've spent my whole life learning
and that's terrible like how am I going
to spend my time and then this thing
comes in it makes you feel better in the
short term and I like to
extrapolate like a completely burn to
the ground Iraq and them trying to
figure out what's next and then a burn
to the ground Appalachia right here's
these manufacturing jobs and they're
just gone overnight we ship them
overseas I like to take those because
they're outside the bell curve and then
shift it to that more common quiet life
of
desperation you may not be doing opiates
but Netflix has taken you don't even
have to change channels anymore it just
starts the next show for you and your
husband's always going to be a little
bit grumpy your wife's always going to
be a little bit distant your kids are
always going to want to hang out with
their friends more than you they're
always gonna have their faces buried in
a
screen and so you may not be you know
snorting ad all off your counter but you
can disappear in your own life right and
it's these I'm just going to you know
what I'm not good at with my I'm not
good at being a parent I'm not good my
wife clearly doesn't like me I'm going
to spend more time at work because I
know I'm good there right and in the
short term I make a little bit more
money I get a little more accolades and
in the long term I create a home that my
kids don't want to come back to after
after college right so it cost me
everything because I become addicted to
this or whatever I become addicted to
just checking out right and I think it's
easy to point fingers at alcohol it's
easy to point fingers at new drugs it's
easy to point fingers at opiates it's
harder to point fingers in the mirror
and say like what am I using in my
day-to-day life for me it was food like
what am I using in my life to not be
present with discomfort right and that's
a gnarly place to find yourself I like
what you mentioned that three prong
approach to addiction cuz to me the
answer is in the middle everybody's
going to experience pain all of us yeah
and there's always going to be Outlets
it's that middle one which is how can I
go get tools right how can I go fill my
toolkit up Beyond just Rage or some
substance what can I what can I fill the
bag up with and you do that so great
here kind of unpacking
that hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free I think I've always told folks I
think happiness is like fireworks and
cocaine like they're shiny and they're
cool and they are terrible Masters and
their terrible destination like they're
it's a it's a dumb place to try to
attain right to try to get to if you
will and it's baked into the DNA of our
country this Pursuit of Happiness that's
like it's wired into who we say we
are and I don't think it's good talk to
me about happiness well yeah and I've I
kind of had always felt like you now at
the same time I I'm a science journalist
ultimately and um in reading a lot of
the research on on happiness like we get
we get this list of things we got to do
to be happy
right the big one now is you must be
social to be happy I'm like I'm not
saying that being social is bad but I am
saying like how do we measure that like
I know plenty of people that prefer to
be alone and they just have one or two
really good friends that seeming are
seemingly some of the most satisfied
people with their lives I've ever met
where it's like you must do X you must
do y you must must do Z all to be happy
and when you start to sort of Peel back
the layers and also use some common
sense you can see that like it's the
keto diet it's the raw vegan it's like
well I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't exactly Jive you science
journalist with your data right data
sucks
um happiness is complex it's confusing
and um so what is sort of understand it
well I'll tell you I'll tell you this
so there's all this list of stuff we
need to do to be happy right and then I
come across some research on these uh
benedic te monks who live in uh New
Mexico and there's a bunch of them
throughout the world
and research shows that they're some of
they're significantly happier than the
average person now when you look at what
they do across the
day their life would kick your butt like
it seem like they're doing all these
things that like don't make sense for
them to be happy they wake up at 3: in
the morning and go pray in the chapel
and they do that seven other times
across the day they do hard physical
labor for four hours they spend a
significant portion of the day not
talking at all they have to be in
silence so they're not super social they
don't have um long story short they have
a pretty hard austere lifestyle that
they've created for themselves that
they've created for themselves and yet
they're happy and so why is that and I
think a lot of it goes back to they're
not trying to be happy right they're
trying to devote to devote thems to this
higher idea so for them it's God they're
trying to do the next right thing that
um is not about themselves they're
getting out of themselves in every
moment and I think that um by following
that by doing what you inherently know
is the next right thing that's going to
help uh other people help the world I
think people wind up happy yes that is
harder right because we often think that
um and I'm guilty of this if I just buy
that one car like that's that's going to
make me happy like my problem is that I
don't have the right car right I don't
have the right purchase I if I my next
happiness is going to be this awesome
new meal I'm going out for like we have
all these things right that we think
going to make us happy but I think
really um when you kind of peel back the
layers on not only the research but also
I mean a lot of just this ancient wisdom
that's been circulating through humans
for as long as we've been around it
really is like get out of yourself find
something bigger than yourself and try
and do the next right thing and help
others and people wind up happy that way
tell me if
this maybe I'm stretching here um so I
wrestled I've wrestled with body
dysmorphia my whole life like um like
even looking at objective measures and
um I was having a meal with Sal de
Stefano the one one of the Mind pump
guys up in San Jose and he's been a
personal Trader for years and he said
something that was was one of those
before and after moments for me and he
said John you can't hate your body into
better shape if you go to the gym every
day because you think you're
disgusting and you beat yourself up for
an hour to be less disgusting you'll
always run out of gas you'll never get
to that place if you wake up every day
and love yourself enough to say dude I
am so invested in feeling better like
I'm worth at least an hour that's how
much value I have then you'll that's
you'll do that indefinitely because
you're on a you're you're on a path now
you're not just sprinting to this
arbitrary Finish
Line it almost almost sounds like if the
finish line is happy you'll never catch
it but if these guys are waking up every
day and saying my path to peace my path
to whatever path to God is I'm not
trying to be less
unhappy yeah I think that works I'm just
trying to do the next right thing
because I'm worth doing the next right
thing and of course 95% of that
Monastery I've hung out with mon like
they all want to still be asleep but
they get up at 3: it's not like they
can't wait to wake up at 3: they'd much
rather sleep till 7:00 but they wake up
at 3: cuz it's the next right thing and
there's a thing about Covenant there's
something about that idea like I said I
was going to do it and I think the
person we lie to the most often in our
worlds is ourselves and so there's
something about keeping a covenant to
God or to whatever but something about
telling the truth to yourself yeah that
ultimately I don't know it feels like I
keep my hands keep doing this I keep
opening up but it feels like freedom and
maybe that's what happiness looks like
but um and also there's there's there's
challenge in how they live it's not like
they're doing easy things all day either
and I think that humans get a lot of
reward from doing from overcoming
challenges yeah and there's probably
good reasons for that that go back to
our past whereas if let's say you're
looking for food and you can't find it
it's like thousands of years ago food is
scarce and you're you're going to one
place you can't find it you're going to
the next you can't find it you can't
find it you can't find it oh my God
we're going to die
and then you find it oh my gosh our
lives are saved it's the most rewarding
food ever and it's it's every week
you're it's the most rewarding thing
right yes and it could be the exact same
food as you'd had a week ago but it was
easy to find but you really value that
that food that was harder to find and so
I think that still today that gets
translated into the things that we have
to work harder for to accomplish where
we often have to go through short-term
discomfort but we get this thing at the
end that gives us a long-term benefit we
value that more so we've both been in
Academia it's like when students um get
an A in my media class they're like kind
of happy but when they get a a in
chemistry or you know geometry or that
really hard stem class going oh my gosh
this is amazing the grades are worth the
same point value but why do we value the
chemistry a over the Michael Easter
journalism 107 Class A because the
chemistry is is a lot harder so should
we be weary of Happiness should I be
nervous about it should I just like
because now I I have a weird
relationship with it now now I'm I'm
super cautious about it and I almost
think I'm hitting the pendulum the other
side right so I I you know when the
Accolade came last week about the book
like John your book did
well I was like that's cool and like I
did one little fist pump and the person
with me was like nope Dela you're going
to celebrate this for a second want two
fist pumps yeah exactly how do you what
kind of relationship should we have with
happiness yeah it's a good question I
mean I think it's honestly it's a lot of
internal searching um I think that you
know my book it it doesn't give you a
perfect road map on how to live your
life because I think that everyone is
different yeah and you know as much as
we lean on data especially people like
you and I when you look at study data
there's always outliers and there's
always it's a range of outcomes and we
just kind of lump them into one and so
what if you're a person who's not
perfectly you know in in the average
group you could be out here or out here
and so I think I think living life is um
it's a journey it's an exploration right
you have to figure out what works for
you uh when why how and that's not often
uh easy or formulaic dude we just want a
recipe though man we just wan to but by
going through that it you learn
something you get such deeper
Rewards and so and also you have to
realize um that we're kind of I'm going
back to something we just talked about
um you mentioned body
dysmorphia a lot of what we um obsess on
or think about or decide that we want
it's so culturally conditioned oh yeah
right
so 200 years ago you would have your
idea of body dysmorphia would have been
a totally different look exactly yeah
right yeah and so what's up with that
right right we it's not real right
conditioned yeah yeah humans are great
because uh we can think in stories and
abstract ideas that's how we you know
were able to cooperate and take over the
globe but on an individual level we can
buy into our own BS yes I love mine I
love mine because mine's always right
Michael mine's always accurate and I'm
guilty of that too you know um and we're
we're constantly moving the goalpost as
well um so that's something I write
about in the comfort crisis with this
idea that you know today's uh today's
Comfort becomes tomorrow's discomfort
and as the world kind of advances over
time I think we can end up adopting some
behaviors that aren't necessarily great
for
us and that means we have to be okay
with well in a world where you and I can
pull our cell phones up right now and
punch a button and food will just show
up here MH we're not we're not evolved
for that no and that we can just walk 15
yards that way and turn a knob and water
comes out we're not evolved for that and
so help us with this um I think this
scarcity brain was such a natural move
from Comfort
crisis but it seems like there's been a
shift in in the human existence really
quick that we have to make peace with
and that is
these th these things on our left used
to take a ton of energy to go get and
they don't and so now our new adventure
is not finding these things in the
moment the new adventure is
injecting fractals into our life
injecting discomfort into our life on a
regular basis so how do we create this I
guess peace with discomfort and how do
we begin to rationally inject discomfort
into our lives something that surprised
me as I was writing the Comfort crisis
is we have injected so much comfort into
our life we often don't even see all the
ways it's in there so I think people
intuitively know like yeah I move a lot
less than I probably would have in the
past yeah food's a lot easier to come by
but think of something like boredom our
relationship with boredom has changed
people are rarely bored anymore we spend
more than 12 to 13 hours engaged with
digital media think about the last time
that's insane all that stuff is new in
the last 100 years it didn't exist think
about the how a human being spends their
time you went from 16 hours probably
outside working interacting with others
all these things and then now we do 12
hours 12 to 13 hours on average um stuff
that's coming through a screen so that's
from computers TVs smartphones and that
changes everything about it it changes
everything about us uh even something
like
so humans came up in Worlds that were
very silent and anytime you heard a loud
noise it was probably bad trying to eat
you someone's trying to eat you there's
a storm coming through with coming over
the hill to kill your yeah and uh We've
since increased the world's loudness by
fourfold and now people say they feel
uncomfortable in silence but what tends
to happen is that after people go
through the discomfort of Silence they
tend to calm down because loud noises we
still associate that kind of in the back
of our brain
and um release the stress hormones and
everything from our relationship with
with death to food to um everything has
changed and to your point about how it's
not we're just trying to do the next
right thing I call these good problems
to have right I would rather uh have the
option of having my food delivered than
literally every single day having to go
out and find it on foot in the cold or
in the desert where you live yeah does
it where I live yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't survive out there very long
give me like 10 minutes
um but making the choice to do hard
things I think we know it keeps us
healthy we know it tends to lead us into
happiness over the long term and so for
me it's um you have to think about uh
all the ways that you can sort
of look into what discomfort might be
able to bring you because I think even
something like boredom like all these
things we we evolve to feel these
discomforts because they kept us alive
in the past but they can still enhance
our life in the present so you know we
know exercise is the best thing you can
do for your health we know that probably
how much we love junk food is probably
not good for us and maybe going through
some Hunger sometime is going to have um
long-term upsides going through boredom
is associated with less stress more
creativity um even just more time
outside like we like to be indoors
because it's climate controlled
everything is certain you don't have to
worry about anything you go outside and
now all of a sudden well it's kind of
cold or it's kind of hot or there could
be an animal in the woods right um but
time in nature is one of the best things
you can do for mental health associated
with all these kinds of great things
even um there's some pretty compelling
research about walking on a treadmill or
on a sidewalk versus walking on grass or
yeah rocks or paths in just that there's
so many there's so many century know
buttons If you will on your feet and in
your legs and then little bitty muscles
that are constantly balancing you and we
just stripped all that out and flattened
everything out and said walk on the
sidewalk and there's probably less
broken feet and less broken ankles and
what have we taken out right and it's
just
simply it's it's hard to convince
somebody myself included that your day
has to be intentionally uncomfortable
for you to be well and whole that seems
so countercultural counter everything
right
right where do we
start well I I mean I think
that another observation I've made is
that some people will be really great at
one thing it could be you know I go to
the gym every day for an hour but what
are the other discomforts that you're
avoiding could be a food thing could be
a boredom thing like they just can't sit
with their thoughts like you know I know
guys will go run Ultra marathons like
drop of a hat but then you go hey why
don't you sit why don't you sit in
silence with your thought thoughts for
five minutes and they're like no NOP do
that Noe no yep yeah and so I think you
need to figure out you know what is your
what is sort of limiting you and what is
the thing that you are most afraid of is
it head into it yeah head right into it
whether it's the gym whether it is you
know I'm going to try and get a hold of
my eating and I realize that I'm
probably going to be hungry at some
point but I also think that it's never
as bad as we think it's going to be
never never never no so I think that
humans sort of evolve to be uh underc
confident and overc
competent say that again underconfidence
and overc competent so let's say we had
to go um you know that makes sense CU if
I'm over confident I get killed right so
think like we got to okay we got to move
our camp you know we got to cross this
big river if you're the person who goes
yeah I I can cross that River no problem
you're dead but you're not that
confident you're like you get swept away
like those people don't die those are
the hold my beer people
right if you are the person who's going
we shouldn't cross I don't want to cross
over I don't think I can do that but you
get in a position where you're forced to
do it and you can accomplish it because
you've undersold yourself that would
give you a survival Advantage every
single time yes so I think that that we
still have that DNA and I think that um
that can limit us people are capable of
way more than they realize like way more
and you see that tend to come out when
we put ourselves in positions to prove
that to oursel MH we need the evidence
of the doing and so I think even just
taking that first step you get in there
and you're like Yeah I wanted to quit
but I got through it and what else can I
do and what else can I do and what else
can I do but it really does take that
first step I mean and people no one's
going to drag you to the gym no one's
going to cut off your subscription to
Uber Eats No One's Gonna shut down your
cell phone because you can't stop
watching Tik Tok like it's not it's just
not going to happen in fact the opposite
you talk about a great and scity
brain for me I remember going down a
rabbit hole about 10 years ago with the
tech folks when the Neuroscience folks
started partnering up and I remember
thinking oh I can't win that like my
only move is disengagement I have to
take the apps off my phone I have to
consider not carrying my phone
everywhere I've got I can't play the
game like when I go to Vegas I have this
much money and it goes in one po ET and
when it's gone it's gone because I can't
control myself the other way my wife can
because I think she's a serial killer
but like I I can't and so it is what it
is right but it's almost as though I
can't have that food in my house I'll
eat it right it's it's almost have to
play disengagement for a season until I
can
slowly um begin to be more
intentional this episode is sponsored by
better help hey it's delone what in the
world is going on listen this is that
time of year Family Travel everyone
telling you what to do the end of the
year fiscal season money politics all of
it and all of it's happening in the dark
because the sun goes down and it doesn't
seem to want to come up Seasonal
effective disorder is real so you put
Darkness on top of all of it and wow it
gets dark at 4:30 where I live live and
I'm ready for bed at 5:45 in the evening
things aren't as fun sometimes even my
food tastes different but now I know I
got to take care of my body I got to get
outside even when it's dark outside or
even when it's early in the morning I
got to move my body I got to put bright
lights in my eyes and I have to
intentionally connect with people and
sometimes intentionally connecting with
people is about friends and other times
intentionally connecting with people is
with therapy therapy can be a bright
spot in the chaos at the end of the year
even when the Sun goes down too soon
something to help you feel positive and
grounded and give you tools to manage
all this madness when nothing else will
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try better
help is flexible because it's totally
online and it can fit into any schedule
you have just fill out a short
questionnaire you're going to get
matched with the licensed therapist and
you switch therapist at any time for no
charge find your bright spot in the
chaos find some peace When Everything
feels like it's spinning out of control
with my friends at betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com delone today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com dealone you're worth
it I want to talk about how our bodies
are designed to carry heavy stuff cuz
that was that was I did not know that
and you paint a really beautiful picture
in the comfort crisis you paint a
beautiful picture of all the rhetoric
the human B the humans are the weakest
animal we're lame we have no horns we
have no fur we have no muscles we're
just weak wimps and you pointed out not
true there's one thing that we do better
than everything else every other animal
and I was like what I and right when you
said it I was like yep that makes
perfect sense yeah U but that was new
for me yeah carrying carrying weight
across distance we're the only animal
that can carry loads across distance and
people will often say well what about
donkeys it's like well yes but the human
has to strap the load onto the donkey so
it's you know they can't do it uh by
themselves um and this totally shaped us
so the way that humans would hunt in the
past is we would slowly but surely run
down an animal uh and we'd bump it and
bump it and bump it because other
animals are not good at cooling
themselves we are so we sweat um all
these different things So eventually
this animal after we chased it for 10
miles it would become exhausted from the
heat it would fall over and then we
would spear it and then we would have
food right but we've got to take it back
to Camp so then what do you do you got
to carry that weight all the way back to
camp and this shaped Us full stop so you
can look at all these different
adaptations we have the reason we are
built the way we are is to carry things
long distances and still today and to
run long distances to get it right run
long distances to get it so in the book
I talk about it's like look people know
running is good for you like jogging's a
thing there are running stores all over
uh but how many people for a workout
carry weight for a significant distance
the answer is not many the um the sort
of tribe that still does is the military
so rucking is a found is the foundation
of training for basically all soldiers
especially Special Forces and rucking is
throwing some weight in the backpack and
basically going for a walk now the
reason that this is so good for people
is uh well there's a handful first of of
all you're also working your strength as
you are doing cardio so you're getting a
two for One MH and this seems to
preferentially burn fat so there's some
really interesting studies on uh
Backcountry hunters and they basically
find that these guys will go out and
they don't have a ton of food and
they'll be out for a week but they're
rucking around with heavy backpacks on
their back and they come back and
they've lost 10 pounds or so but their
muscle has stayed the same wow if they
were running without the weight it would
have probably been about equal right
yeah um it's also a lot less injurious
than running so everyone's probably run
and afterwards you know your knee hurts
or you're whatever you stopped running
because
XYZ um rucking injury rate is way lower
it's about the same as walking which is
if you can if you can walk you can rock
um the next question I always get is how
much weight should I use and I always
tell people start slow or start low you
know start with 10 15 pounds if you're a
bigger person maybe 20 see how that
feels add weight from there um Don't Go
Over a third of your body weight though
that seems to you get diminishing
returns the injury rate starts to go up
a little bit it's just not really worth
it what it for yeah yeah that um I can
think of no other move in my life over
the last three years um that's made a
significant contribution to My overall
health and fitness and it gets me
outside and it it gets me that same burn
I guess when you're lifting weights but
also gets the it was just awesome and
there's something I I don't know if you
experienc this I take that weight off
and I can't describe it other than I
feel like a million box I just feel so
good and it's a strange I don't know if
it's just psychosomatic I don't know
what it is but I just feel right when I
throw that backpack off and it's I'm
tired but it just it's just right yeah
and the other reason I love it too is
you can do it with people other people
yeah so if you're running one person is
going to have like if I want to go for a
run with my mom who's 70 three like
first of all she's not going to want to
run but if she does I'm going to
basically be in a fast walk and I'm not
getting a great workout if I want to
rock with my mom I could throw in 45 lbs
she could have a 5B plate and we'd go at
the same speed and we'd get at pretty
equal effect and we can have a
conversation we can connect we can do uh
all these things that humans are
basically born to do yeah which just go
out into nature together do something
physical have a conversation while you
do it I mean it's just you're ticking so
many boxes that are for people that's
been transformative quite honestly um
Michael Easter the marriage counselor
for my marriage and it started about two
years ago with hey let's just go go for
a walk we live out in the country let's
just go for a walk and I'm was got ancy
and it was about an hour or two hour
walk I got ansy so then the next time I
just threw my backpack on with my wife
and we have fought we have wept together
over the last two years we have solved
big issues in our marriage we have
planned vacations and trips and what are
we going to do about schools we've had
some really intimate time
and I get to have 35 or 45 pounds in my
backpack while we're walking and so I'm
getting a good exercise and it's double
and triple and quadruple dipping and
when you're a dad and you got two kids
and you have a full-time job and she's
running those hours become sparse and
man it's been such a gift to our
marriage that we can go at the same Pace
yet have two different things
metabolically going on in our B at the
same time it's been
incredible last thing I want to cover
um and I couldn't I couldn't believe it
when I read it in scarcity brain you
like me don't land on a here's the
step-by-step path for spirituality but I
felt like we both landed in the same
place that you have to take a need of
something bigger than you is happening
and if you find yourself at the center
of the universe that's almost the
Bedrock for
addiction that's almost the Bedrock for
misery which is everything revolves
around me walk me through how you landed
from cuz you you you mean you started in
Baghdad and you end up in New Mexico and
I end up in a doctor's office and end up
at a Mexican food restaurant with a monk
like and we both end up in almost the
same place walk me through how you got
from there to there and then how do you
think about this idea of submission or
sitting in the presence of something
bigger than you
yeah that's a great question
um I'll tell you this the night before I
got sober one of my best friends goes do
you believe in God and I said dude if
someone needs a set of rules a Hocus
Pocus rules to live a good life and be a
decent human that person is full of it
m so I you know I say that and then I go
out to the bars and behave like a
complete idiot so you can see how far my
head was up my butt in that situation I
wake up and for whatever reason I tried
to quit drinking tons and tons of times
many times and for whatever reason that
morning I could just see down field we
like if you keep drinking that'll solve
your problems in the short term over
time but you're going to die early full
stop or you can take the second path
which is to get sober and it's going to
be the hardest thing you ever do but on
the other side of that I felt like there
was something there so I like to say
it's it's almost like God heard my lines
the night before and went yeah watch
this sucker hold my
beer and uh after I got sober uh I do I
do think there was something higher at
play I just I just feel that way um and
that changed my thinking and getting out
of myself a key for me to stay
sober is to do things to get out of
myself and um my experience is in and
from reporting the Comfort crisis to
reporting scarcity brain and traveling
have very much
been trying to unpeel that onion which
is very complicated right these are
questions that everyone has been
grappling with for a very long time all
time yeah and I think I've basically
just landed on the fact that I
personally my idea of spirituality I
believe there's absolutely something
higher than myself bigger than myself
there's some higher order to all this at
the same time I don't have to understand
I can be okay with being like you know
what I don't know exactly what it is um
and I'm also extremely respectful of
anyone who all religions if you feel
like you uh know what works great I'm
not going to argue with anyone like that
like I just I just have a lot more um
empathy and respect for people and
trying to do the next right thing like
the sort of Monk
said has enhanced my life full stop more
importantly the lives of those around me
so when I get sober it's not just that
like oh great Michael's you know not
going to die at 45 or whatever it is
it's that now all of a sudden my
girlfriend has a better life in turn her
family has a better life in turn the
people they work with have a better life
like there are big Downstream effects
from that sort of uh decision and I've
also noticed that when I start to fall
back to not doing the next right thing
that's sort of reverse this course and
it's a good reminder that um you know it
is this sort of constant battle and if I
can say anything about what I've learned
along the way is that it's a battle
everyone's fighting you know and you can
see once people start to really focus on
themselves not only did they start to
become more likely to be miserable but
so do the people in their
orbit and do you want that yeah no and I
also don't think there I find that there
is zero correlation between wealth and
um living a good life like full stop
I've been to countries where people have
like I go to Bhutan right there's not a
stop light in a single country in the
country in the whole country there's not
a Starbucks there's not a McDonald's um
people aren't walking around on iPhones
MH they're the happiest people I've ever
encountered the nicest Joy they're
present um and it's one of the least
developed countries on Earth by G
and so I really think that you know the
battle for us today is um realizing that
we are surrounded in such abundance and
opportunity and uh wealth and just I
mean it's an amazing time to be alive it
really is but I think that comes with
perils too where we can start to you
know focus more on getting the next
thing and not as much on sharing and
trying to help others and um it was a
long rambling way of answering question
I appreciate that that's awesome I think
that bringing your eyes out of your own
belly button changes everything yeah hey
man this is fun I appreciate you being a
good friend and you've been a big help
to me behind closed doors and so I'm
grateful to you and um
Everybody if you don't have this book in
Your Hands by the end of this interview
you're doing something wrong with your
life and I I I I don't say that lightly
um please go pick this up and if you
have to choose between this one and you
haven't bought mine yet buy this one
first get this book scarcity brain from
the great Michael Easter thank you so
much my brother I'm grateful for you I'm
gonna disagree with that you did a you
did you did an amazing job on your bu I
appreci very helpful I've had family
members who literally sent me a picture
of it cuz I had the little blurb you
blurbed this I read this book and it's
helped me well I appr that full stop so
nice work man thank you
[Music]
man hey what's up delone here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
delone.org a DieHard dead head Grateful
Dead fan to the very end in fact he
booked a ticket and went and saw them in
San Francisco for their final show he is
all in and so the song of the day is my
favorite Grateful Dead song mainly
because I forgot to ask him what his
favorite one was but the song's called
trucken and I first heard this song when
Tesla covered it as a part of their
fiveman acoustical Jam album which is
one of the greatest records ever ever
ever in the history of humankind
but the great Trucking by The Grateful
Dead and it goes like this Trucking got
my chips cashed in keep trucking like
the dudah man together more or less in
line just keep on trucking arrows of
neon and flashing Marquees out on Main
Street Chicago New York Detroit and it's
all on the same street your typical City
involved in a typical Daydream hang it
up and see what tomorrow
brings Trucking like the dudah man
that's what we called Joe sometimes when
he's not around once told me you've got
to play your hand sometimes your cars
ain't worth a dime if you don't lay them
down man shout out to the great Michael
Easter go pick up scarcity brain go pick
up the Comfort crisis two of the most
important books you will read in the
next decade I love you guys stay in
school don't do drugs
bye